das fbi hat jane mexiko festgenommen
eine mutmaßliche komplizin von jeffrey
epstein jetzt im us staat new hampshire
wurde sie festgenommen
sie steht im verdacht apps ging und
seinen pädophilen ring immer wieder
minderjährige frauen beschafft zu haben
und genau darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit meinen kollegen us außen
korrespondent herbert bauernebel herbert
was genau wird ihr vorgeworfen weil sie
diese mädchen immer wieder gehabt haben
das sind ganz dramatische entwicklung
natürlich maxwell ist angeklagt in
dieser anklageschrift hier die vom
southern district in new york in lower
manhattan man sieht das gerichtsgebäude
hinter mir verabschiedet worden ist oder
eingebracht worden ist aufgrund dieser
anklage gab es den haftbefehl der fbi
beamten und die haben zugeschlagen
morgens um 8 uhr 30 im ort bradford in
new hampshire in dieser in dieser
anklage wird detailliert festgehalten
die vorwürfe gegen mister maxwell
natürlich stand an der seite von sex
straftäter jepsen der im vorjahr tot in
seiner zelle gefunden wurde und war zeit
eine zeit lang mit ihm sogar liiert
seine freundin was einer
geschäftspartnerin und daneben ihre
rolle als praktisch als madame fast als
zuhälterin eigentlich die ihr jetzt
vorgeworfen wird von dem gericht in new
york in dieser klage wird werden konkret
drei fälle beschrieben von drei zeugen
eines handelt sich um einen zeitrahmen
zwischen 1994 und 1997 und hier wird
immer wieder hingewiesen wie das ganze
system funktioniert haben es lena
maxwell hat diese jungen mädchen
befreundet hat das vertrauen zu ihnen
hergestellt hat sie sogar zum shopping
mitgenommen sind ins kino gegangen
dann hat sie sie eben jeffrey epstein
zugeführt und während dieser illegalen
sexuellen beziehungen hat sie auch das
den ganzen sexuellen missbrauch
praktisch normalisiert auch in
gesprächen mit den opfern es handelt
sich angeführt werden hier drei konkrete
vier konkrete tatorte eigentlich zu
einem die wohnung von chefs ding hier in
new york seine villa in west palm beach
in florida eine ranch in new mexico und
auch seine wohnung
ihre wohnung eigentlich in london jetzt
war max abgetaucht sein wurde zuletzt so
heißt es in paris gesichtet wie ist das
fbi jetzt auf ihre spur gekommen
es ist eigentlich erstaunlich dass sie
sollte sie wirklich in europa gewesen
sein dass sie in die usa hier
zurückgekehrt ist es ist wirklich
eigentlich fassungslos wie viele
experten hier sagen dass sie sich derart
in eine derartige gefahr gegeben habe
verhaftet zu werden offensichtlich war
das fbi auf der spur hat sie
offensichtlich überwacht und es kam dann
eben zu diesem zugriff der überraschend
war für viele hier in den usa man hatte
eigentlich hier fast gar nicht mehr
gerechnet mit einer anklage gegen die ex
partnerin und so gesehen ist es ein
natürlich ein großer schritt vorwärts in
der ganzen apps dienstag ein großer
puzzlestein fehlt natürlich noch
schießler maxwell war gleichzeitig auch
eine gute bekannte gute freundin von
prinz andrew in einem wichtigen mitglied
der königlichen familie in
großbritannien und diese ermittlungen
sind zuletzt darauf festgefroren
eigentlich weil das britische königshaus
wie man hört die zusammenarbeit mit den
amerikanischen behörden verweigert jetzt
wird natürlich darauf gewartet was
maxwell jetzt auch sagen könnte zu ihrer
beziehung mit prinz andrew dem ja auch
vorgeworfen wird wurde in vielen klagen
hier in den usa das er ebenfalls sich
junge mädchen zu führen hat lassen von
von mexiko